you've studied many
american presidents throughout history
so
who do you think was the greatest
president in american history
the greatest american president was
abraham lincoln and
tolstoy reflected on this himself
actually uh
saying that uh when he was in the
caucasus he asked these
um peasants in the caucuses who was the
greatest man in the world that they had
heard of
and they said abraham lincoln and why
well because he gave voice to people who
had no voice before
he turned politics into an art this is
what tolstoy recounted the peasants and
the caucuses telling him
uh lincoln made politics more than about
power he made it an art he made it a
source of liberation
and those living even far from the
united states could see
that uh model that inspiration uh from
lincoln
he was a man who had two years of
education yet he mastered the english
language
and he used the language to
help people imagine a different kind of
world you see leaders and presidents are
at their best
when they're doing more than just
manipulating institutions in power
when they're helping the people imagine
a better world and he did that
as no other president has and you say he
gave
he gave voice to those who are voiceless
uh who are you talking to
about in general is this about
african-americans or is this about
just the populist in general certainly
part of it is about uh
slaves uh african-americans and many
immigrants uh
immigrants from all parts of europe and
other areas that have come to the united
states
but part of it was just for ordinary
american citizens the republican party
for which lincoln was the first
president
was a party created to give voice to uh
poor white men as well as uh slaves and
others
and lincoln was a poor white man himself
grew up without slaves and without land
which meant you had almost nothing
what do you think about the trajectory
of that man with only two years of
education
is there something to be said about how
does one come from
nothing and
nurture the ideals that kind of make
this country great
into something where you can actually be
a leader of this nation
to espouse those ideas to give the voice
to the voiceless
yes i think i think you actually hit the
nail on the head i think
uh what he represented was uh the
opportunity and that was the word that
mattered for him
opportunity that came from the ability
to
raise yourself up to work hard and to be
compensated for your hard work and this
is at the core of the republican party
of the 19th century which is
the core of capitalism it's not about
getting rich it's about getting
compensated for your work
it's about being incentivized to do
better work and lincoln was constantly
striving one of his
closest associates uh herndon said
he was the little engine of ambition
that couldn't stop he just just kept
going
taught himself to read taught himself to
be a lawyer he went through many failed
businesses before he even reached that
point
many failed love affairs but he kept
trying he kept working
and what american society offered him
and what he wanted american society to
offer everyone else
was the opportunity to keep trying to
fail and then get up
and try again what do you think was the
nature of that ambition was there a
hunger for power
i think lincoln had a hunger for success
i think he had a hunger
to um get out of the poor station he was
in
he had a hunger to be someone who had
control over his life
freedom for him did not mean the right
to do anything you want to do
but it meant the right to be secure from
being dependent upon someone else
so independence uh he writes in his
letters when he's very young that he
hated being dependent on his father he
grew up without a mother
his father was a struggling farmer and
he would write in his letters that his
father treated him like a slave on the
farm
some think his hatred of slavery came
from that experience
he didn't ever want to have to work for
someone again he wanted to be free and
independent and he wanted again every
american this is the kind of
jeffersonian dream
to be the owner of themself and the
owner of their future
you know that's a really nice definition
of freedom we often think
kind of this very abstract notion of
being able to do anything you want
but really it's ultimately breaking
yourself free from
the the constraints like the very
tight dependence on whether it's the
institutions
or on your family or the expectations or
the community or whatever
be able to be to realize yourself
within the constraints of your own
abilities it's still not
true freedom because true freedom is
probably sort of uh
almost like designing a video game
character or something like that i agree
i think uh i think it's exactly right i
think freedom is not
uh that i can have any outcome i want i
can't control outcomes the most powerful
freeze person in the world cannot
control
outcomes but it means at least i get to
make choices someone else doesn't make
those choices for me
is there something to be said about
lincoln and
on the political game front of it
which is he's accomplished some of them
i i don't know
but it seems like there's some tricky
politics going on
we tend to not think of it in those
terms because of
the dark aspects of slavery we tend to
think about it in sort of ethical and
human terms
but in in their time it was probably
as much a game of politics not just
these broad
questions of human nature right it was
it was a game
so is there something to be said about
being a skillful player in the game of
politics that
you'd take from lincoln absolutely and
um
lincoln never read carl von clausewitz
the great 19th century german thinker on
strategy and politics but but he
embodied
the same wisdom which is that everything
is politics if you want to get anything
done
uh and this includes even relationships
uh
there's a politics to it what does that
mean it means that you you have to
persuade
coerce encourage people to do things
they wouldn't otherwise do
and lincoln lincoln was a master at that
he was a master that for two reasons he
had learned through his hard life to
read people
to anticipate them to spend a lot of
time listening one thing i often tell
people is the best leaders or the
listeners not the talkers
and then second um lincoln was very
thoughtful and planned
every move out he was thinking three or
four moves maybe five moves down the
chess board
while others were move number one or two
that's fascinating to think
about him just listening to studying
that's uh you know
they they look at great fighters in this
way like the first few rounds of boxing
and mixed martial arts you're studying
the movement of your opponent
in order to sort of uh to find the holes
that's that's a really interesting frame
to think about it
you